the european union is bending over
backwards to try to get this deal over
the line i mean it's a triumph for boris
isn't it
uh well let's see if they agree to it
first i think it's probably a good basis
for negotiation i mean some of it is
being briefed that they're going to just
reject it but i don't think that they
should um
we need to make sure that we have
something which is permanent we can't
just continue to kind of keep kicking
the can down the road which is what
we're doing at the moment
um
i mean there being stability in northern
ireland is important for all kinds of
reasons obviously politically but also
economically
last year northern ireland got the least
amount of inward investment of any of
the regions or nations within the united
kingdom you know there was a thousand we
only think only less than a thousand
jobs were created and part of the
northern ireland agreement was in order
to engender
optimism and for people to be confident
that it was that it was a good thing to
invest in northern ireland so for
northern ireland's future it's really
important that we're clear about what
its relationship ongoing commercial
relationship is with the european union
and with with the rest of the uk he's
managed to get them to drop 80 percent
of the checks on goods going into
northern ireland that's amazing it's
kind of complicated actually what it is
i think is there there will be a
a series of
there's arrangements whereby people have
to make and that i have to declare that
those goods are only going to be within
northern ireland i think there's some
stickers
putting a sticker on it and they will
then monitor it and see if it works and
if it doesn't then you know then there's
room for it to to fall back afterwards
so the checks that are made need to be
done properly and need to be done by the
british government in a proper way
but all of this is good i continue to be
a bit concerned about medicines
and i what i want and i have told the
europeans this is that we must allow a
british
doctor in in belfast to be able to
prescribe the same medicines as you
would get prescribed in bolton and i'm a
little bit concerned about the stiller
border both ways about that because they
because medicines being used in northern
ireland need to not only be
be certified as safe in the european
union it also needs to be certified as
safe within the uk and so it kind of
just makes it so tied up in red tape
that you might well find in the future
fewer medicines being available to
people in northern ireland that would be
available in britain and that can't the
rest of britain and that can't be right
but the broad overview you have to
acknowledge that he boris johnson and
lord frost have done a good job
the board you'll bring yourself to seven
the broad overview of this is that they
signed up to an agreement that wasn't
workable and that i'm glad to see that
attempts are being made to make it more
workable
and i want to see that on both sides
because i think once we have sorted out
the issue of northern ireland then there
are all kinds of issues with our trade
with the rest of europe all kinds of
holes within the the agreement you know
if we want to make brexit work then
there needs to be more work done but you
acknowledge that they've done a
reasonably good job i acknowledge that
they are doing a good job in terms of
continuing to negotiate and let's make
sure that they do actually agree
something so they patched the holes in
the agreement that they signed that
wasn't really fit for purpose in the
first place and cummings said that they
were never going to um abide by all of
the rules and they were going to change
them as when they went along keeping the
bits that they wanted and getting rid of
the others that what does that say
to others that you know australians
japanese whoever else we're doing trade
deals with
britain has always had a reputation for
being a country that is that upholds
international law in fact frankly an
awful lot of international law was
written by british lawyers
so for us to start playing fast and
loose with other countries is
is shameful i think that we step down as
a country we don't have the same
international reputation if we if our
word isn't our bond
and i'm really i think it's appalling
that people would even think of
representing our country and signing up
to an agreement knowing that they
weren't going to implement it i think
it's appalling
you paused before you said shameful what
word were you going to use i wasn't
going to use a word that you could
probably broadcast on the sky
in which case i'm glad you did
thank you for that um talk to me about
what you've been reading in the papers
this morning about gps and uh the fact
that they're not seeing enough people
face to face yes yes i mean it's a it's
a struggle isn't it to get to see a gp
it's uh and i think that there's a
backlog of work and there's a number of
things people want now they feel safe to
go and see their gp that people want to
get access to them so there are attempts
being made to reorganize things let's
see if this works i mean in the end it's
not any new money to the national health
service so i'm not sure
it might well be just robbing peter to
pay paul but
um and and some people do feel do find
it easier to get a faster appointment
and just speak to their doctor on the
telephone or on zoom you know and if
that's how that works too and what's
wrong with that exactly but i think in
the end
i think the general feeling is is that
you need it's better to see the whole
person
how you walk how you sit how you are you
know it's also an important part of the
diagnosis so there needs to be a range
of things but what we can't have
is for there to continue to be such
difficulties to see a gp face to face
also what we can't have is half of our
gps are saying to the bma that they're
depressed i spoke to a gp this morning
and he said who's actually making policy
is it the nhs is it sadie javid um or is
it the daily mail yes i understand that
and in the end you know we've also of
course heard today that one in five
public sector workers are thinking of
leaving and i think that
we do need to
remember how valuable they are what all
everything that they have been through
during the craving crisis we've all had
a difficult time but those that have
kept our public services going are
absolutely the people who you know we
stood on the doorsteps and clapped them
but we need to continue to remember how
important they are and and the long-term
effects of the amount of work that
they've had to put in in order to help
us all through do you feel that labour's
doing enough though to try to support um
our medical team i mean your leader is
actually married to a medic isn't he yes
well i i mean i think that we do i think
we do everything that we can to listen
to
why
why aren't you in power then
oh well that's another issue um i think
that we're not in power because the last
general election was an issue just it
was an election just about brexit
and uh and i think that we should have
had a a referendum about that not a
general election but there we are it's
in the past they now have a an 80 seat
majority they have an ability to make
brexit work not just to continue to be a
campaigning
organization they ought to be governing
the conservative party ought to be now
they're in power they ought to be making
responsible mature decisions difficult
decisions and bringing our country
forward and out of the mess that we're
in at the moment yeah i mean cummings
again quoting him and sorry about that
but i'm going to um he said the reason
that he supported boris even though he
thinks he's an idiot is because that he
was a better idiot than the guy that was
running the labour party at the time and
isn't that what the rest of the country
thought
no i think that what the rest of the
country thought was that i mean the
polling all shows that the primary um
thing that they were making a decision
about was about brexit and they wanted
brexit over and done with and this idea
that boris johnson had an oven-ready
deal you know put it in at gas mark 3
was something which appealed to people
but we have discovered since the truth
which is that we need to continue to
work on making sure that we have a good
deal with the european union and we have
something on paper but it still has lots
of holes in it and i'm afraid we have to
continue to work on it final thought
your former leader supported
an mp who has had the whip removed from
her um claudia webb even though he knew
that
she had been um
charged with threatening a rival a love
rival with the acid in her face
what should happen to her now she's
facing jail
i'm really
shocked to hear of this i mean i know
claudia and this wasn't a sign of
claudia that i was aware of i think that
she should resign i'm afraid i've known
claudia a long time she was a counselor
in my constituency she was well
respected as i say all of this has come
as a great shock but
i think that given that she has been
convicted this is a serious matter i do
think that she should stand down and
you're prepared for another by-election
yes of course